good afternoon everybody
I'm Gary Tomlinson the director of the
Whitney Humanities Center and and since
it's always important for us to get out
set set out straight and first of all
where the food and drink will be served
there will be a reception afterwards and
it's going to be straight back down the
hall behind the auditorium you're all
welcome to come and we hope you will
hilton halls is resident this semester
at the Whitney under the auspices of the
Frankie Visiting Fellows Program this
program is made possible by the generous
support of rich and Barbara Frankie over
many years rich and Barbara have
supported many many initiatives at Yale
and they've been unstinting in their
advocacy for the Whitney Humanities
Center they're here this afternoon right
down here and I'd like you to join me in
thanking them for their wonderful
support
[Applause]
thank you so much rich and Barbara I've
spent seven seven years plus at this
point as the director thanking you for
lots of things and I'm still thanking
you so thank you again to introduce
Hilton Alice this afternoon I will
welcome to the podium Roderick a
Ferguson professor of women's gender and
sexuality studies and American Studies
here at Yale professor Ferguson is a
recent arrival from Chicago and a
brilliant new star in Yale's humanities
faculty in books such as one-dimensional
queer of 2019 we demand the University
and student protests at 2017 and the
reorder of things the University and his
pedagogy is of minority difference of
2012 professor Ferguson has offered
deeply thought analyses of 50 years of
student protests movements and almost as
many years of gay liberation these
analyses are critiques also of the ways
in which student protests and the neo
disciplines they have stimulated have
not only brought about reformations
within the university but at the same
time have been co-opted by forces
reasserting status quos and the
foundation of our universities inflows
of global capital and of the ways in
which are thinking about gay rights has
focused on sexual freedom at the expense
of many other dimensions involved in
such rights including race gender and
class issues connected to colonialism to
the incarceration culture and again to
neoliberal capital in each case
professor Ferguson has voiced a powerful
call for reimagining of Liberatore
thought and liberation movements so join
me please in welcoming our introducer
professor Sir Roderick Ferguson
[Applause]
all right it's my pleasure an honor to
introduce professor Hilton Al's Hilton
as a staff writer and chief theater
critic at The New Yorker he is the
author of two award-winning books the
women from 1996 and white girls from
2013 which was shortlisted for the
National Book Critics Circle Award and
won the lambda literary award in 2016 he
received a Windham Campbell Prize for
Literature and was awarded the Pulitzer
Prize for criticism in 2017 he is also a
former Guggenheim Fellow and is an
associate professor in the writing
program at Columbia University he has
also taught courses here most recently
one on the writer James Baldwin we
should also add curator to his
impressive dossier he has in fact
organized exhibitions on the painter
Alice Neel on Baldwin and on the artist
Lynette
Yoda and Bochy that exhibit is on view
at the Yale Center for British art one
of the ways that I have recently come to
frame Hilton's work is through the black
feminist theorists hortence pillars
classic essay Mama's baby
Papa's may be an American grammar book
which begins as as an analysis of the
figurations of black womanhood she
writes quote let's face it I am a marked
woman but not everybody knows my name
peaches and brown sugar sapphire and
earth mother auntie granny God's holy
fool a miss evany furs or black woman at
the podium I described a locus of
confounded identities a meeting ground
of investments and privations in the
national treasury of rhetorical wealth
my country needs me and if I were not
here I would have to be invented in
quote we can think of Hilton's books as
investigations of those loci of
confounded identities those meeting
grounds of investments and privations
that in addition to
Tooting the national treasury of
rhetorical wealth are also the
repositories of the stupefying
contradictions that make up what we know
as race gender class and sexuality his
is a lyrical confrontation with that
American grammar book in both works he
deals with the ways in which
self-destruction and self reduction
become forms of agency how their
debilitation czar inscribed on life and
writing and how those inscriptions are
not simply the stuff that innervate life
and writing but paradoxically and sadly
stir them to purpose despite his
objections to being known as an observer
his observations about social and
psychic life are key and unavoidable in
this capacity he tries to be another
kind of writer one that eschews what he
addresses as the dubious legacy of many
prior and existing writers ones who use
politics to avoid what the artist is
obliged to confront the messiness of
interior t his is a prose that strives
for intellectual honesty and literary
grace a combination that produces a
language that is often sublime and
chilling an artistic practice that
balances linguistic beauty with searing
truth his talk today is entitled the
walk please give a warm welcome to
Hilton Alice
[Applause]
could be your head let me know if you
have any trouble hearing me at all but
my first thing has to go to the center
where Gary and Mark have provided me
time away from weekly criticism to
really explore things that I had started
and had to stop because of financial
concerns as Joan Didion says you have to
figure out a way to make a living
because you nobody can write a book a
year a home and it's been such a
profound moment to be able to stay in
the hotel for three days and to really
explore areas of my mind that otherwise
I would not have been able to explore so
my deepest gratitude to the center
justify wait for mister Tomlinson for
mark who first suggested this I'm very
honored and not even second but Rob I
hope Lea gave you my email message I had
this back issue and I couldn't move so I
couldn't get to see and hear you today
that's audience sympathy if supposed to
say ah and he made it and yeah guarantee
is and so I really feel sorry about that
especially because I know you to be an
impeccable scholar not only that but the
thing that makes him humanities
professor humane is their feeling and
trust and love and understanding of
other people so I'm deeply grateful for
your introduction and I'm going to take
every course you ever give after that
I'm going to read something that I would
not have had
there were two pieces actually that the
center gave me time to write and the
first one was about Lynette and that I
have to give great tanks to an amazing
woman named Amy Myers who instituted the
lecture series at Yale who kept
apologizing about this and that but
there was nothing ever to be sorry for
Amy
it really has opened my mind and I I
want to thank you for changing my life
and this piece so that was one piece
that I was able to write while I was
here and then the second is a revision
of something that I tried to write a
while ago it just didn't work and it was
commodified in ways that were sort of
silly but I was able to do a revision of
it and that's what you'll hear tonight
and I'm again deeply grateful for what
every writer needs which is time some
months ago actually it's over two years
now I moved from one part of Manhattan
to another the distance wasn't
tremendous less than a mile but the
psychological shift was sizable I was
vacating a kind of weigh station that
passed as a home for a room of my own
even though I'd lived in the apartment I
was leaving for over 20 years
I'd shared it with a number of friends
some gone now and to many ideas about
what constituted generosity and
receptivity if you have a roof of your
head that it behooves you to share with
others no matter the financial and
spiritual cost giving might make someone
else anyone else better that was my
mother's ethos she raised me and my five
siblings in Brooklyn my father did not
live with us he was more or less
supported by his mother in our large
house not too far away he had a room in
her house at the very top of it and it
was sang Chris act you didn't enter it
uninvited I never questioned my parents
away
it was the way it was but in the years
leading up to my leaving my first
Manhattan apartment which by the way I'd
moved into the year my mother died in
1989 I was born in 1960
I felt crowded in it or more accurately
crowded out of it
let me explain even though I ostensibly
lived alone in that flat surrounded by
piles books records photographs
magazines my heart my body had been
afflicted by emotional piles for a long
time before I left all that junk behind
you see everything I'd learned about
hospitality from my mother she who was
every child's moral barometer
even if she's broken had caved in on my
soul I could no longer sustain the
platonic soup kitchen I'd been raised to
stop and preside over I could no longer
maintain my mother's lessons of the
heart by the end of my stay my first day
in New York in that New York place
although sometimes excellent and
sometimes not bodies that had crossed my
threshold had impressed themselves on me
no matter how the relationship was
defined it didn't matter if the
day-to-day friendship had dissolved or
the person had died or what-have-you
those former friends bodies were now a
part of my body and I could no longer
bear their weight or the weight of any
of it then love called
rather unexpectedly love didn't so much
edge those bodies out as asked for a
different place to house itself a new
home with less of everything that was
not love no pill pilgrims progress
burdens or treating time as though it
were valuable to others but not myself
love taught me that my time was my own
mine to say mine was evil if you came
from all my school of things it was a
way of killing my and
of goodwill off a way of being like all
those others who hurt MA and in hurting
ma hurt me love pushed against that and
how quote unquote mine was forbidden
when I was growing up our ma supported
us in part with help from public
assistance welfare some images from
those days caseworkers going through her
cabinets to make sure she didn't have a
Questor bread or man or anything that
could contribute to her well-being let
alone to her let alone that of her
children if so no more government help
no more standing with my sister to get
well food food off the truck
no more social workers asking what your
daily life is like as a way of finding
out what your mother is up to you
personally or whether or not she was
mothering you at all love pushed against
all that and wanted something else
including the right to ask the questions
I never never thought of for myself
given that I had been trained by Mars
idea of love not to love
another question love asked why didn't
pause during all those years of lying
and not lying about his absence give his
family any nourishment take his kids in
before making at least one kid sick wood
tinned meat love pushed against that all
that and this to the feeling that if I
had my own place and a lock and the key
I would be no better than our paw
wrapped up safe as can be and soft and
his cocoon of a room nursing on the
overly sweet note of self-protection a
mother's indulgence constant self regard
love assured me that having a space to
work one that wasn't entirely at the
mercy of other people I had known which
is to say Mars legacy of giving unto
death didn't have to be a thing in fact
it could be dismantled brick by brick
so that out of the prison of Mars days I
could be a free man taught to praise
love was the principal architect of my
new place in the principal
of the past the primary feature of my
new apartment is light there are windows
on either side of a floor through in a
part of town that's notable for its
proximity to the Hudson River or
retaining vestiges of bohemian New York
trees a square crooked ol streets with
Dutch or Flemish names few if any of us
know the story behind history takes too
much time
we are Manhattan Heights and preoccupied
by our lives in Manhattan sometimes love
stays for the night and other nights
love cooks meals and in between these
pleasures there's the fear of love
removing his presence how will it go
must it though what is it doing now what
is it doing without me have I done
enough for it to stay are you my mother
if you love me enough will I be my
father and lock the door letting no one
in love encourages me to go get to the
desk built in the room where I work and
to even shut the door from his love in
order to get whatever it is I need to
get done done love can't always stay
love were it weighs on me not in the
same way that I'm sorry love weighs on
me not in the same way those other
bodies did in the days when I followed
Maas ethos to the tea love is not here
sometimes he's out working or making a
meal or sitting in a room far off or on
the other side of a joke and yet there's
Love's presence in a disfiguring world
and then there is your distribut body
the one that is misshapen by words and
offence love cannot follow you into and
you do not want love to follow you into
shaped as it is by the one irrefutable
loneliness I thought was the world the
street leading to my house runs east to
west a trajectory that takes you from a
once quote-unquote bad neighborhood to a
very nice one in any case it's difficult
to find a bad neighborhood and
and now everything has been bought and
made better here in the land of the
Plenty the horn of the good I spent
several mornings a week on the east side
of my block dealing with personal stuff
including how to physically and mentally
defend myself against those who do not
feel my I should exist at all
sometimes this begins even before love
finds me for the day or night that ill
will that bill wind that follows me down
my street the way thoughts followed
virginia woolf down the road and her si
street haunting written in 1930 quote
how beautiful Street is in winter it is
at once revealed and obscured here
vaguely one can trace symmetrical
avenues of doors and windows here under
the lamps are floating islands of pale
light through which passed quickly
bright men and women who for all their
poverty and shabbiness wear a certain
look of unreality an air of triumph as
if they had given life to slit said that
life deceived of her prey blunders on
without them but after all we're not we
are only gliding smoothly on their
surface the eye is not a minor not a
driver not a seeker after buried
treasure
it floats smoothly down a stream resting
causing the brain sleeps perhaps as it
looks
unquote but I'm not gliding down the
surface of my thoughts as I make my way
from the east side of my street down to
the west in part because I am NOT
Virginia Woolf which is to say I do not
go unobserved in the world of my street
thus making me free to observe in
relative safety and peace in the world
of my street I'm observed for a variety
of reasons and this individual and
collective surveillance shapes my
thoughts and my writing in ways that I
resent who wouldn't want to spend an
evening having a walk in search of a
pencil and coming back home without
incident to think about it the way I'm
observed means my brain can't stop sleep
as I look that's a luxury I can't afford
as I tried to not kill the world that
means to kill me from the time I moved
into my new home the windows letting as
my
nature as possible in Manhattan but
really several years before that even
even I felt something in Manhattan that
even love couldn't protect me from and
what shall I call it that may I see your
ID syndrome on my block there's a big
store part of a chain that sells
electronic devices I've been in the shop
exactly three times wants to get a
device fixed once to buy a Christmas
gift with my white German goddaughter
and wants to replace and missing
something to fix another device each
time I've gone into the store had done
my business and I'm about to pay I've
been asked for my ID I am not asleep to
the fact that none of the other
customers usually effluent Europeans
yuppie mothers and the like are not
asked for anything with their credit
cards once they belly up to the
electronic bar to make a purchase for
those of us who are not them the
exchange of capital for goods becomes a
kind of sick room may I see your ID the
sickroom glows with blood the blood that
floods your face in your neck your back
as you hand over your ID instead of what
a [ __ ] you and why not [ __ ] you two
because the worker who asked you for
your ID is black or Hispanic and male 2
and he needs to make a living even if
it's at someone else's someone's literal
and figurative expense he can't look at
you a side note this is always the point
in a story when you become a third
person figure your body can't bear it
and so becomes a different body watching
us things happen we're trying not to
feel despite the rush of blood to the
face the neck the back in this situation
and others like it your eye recedes
running further and further back into
the hidden world housed in the body that
world hates he looked at you smiling as
you decided to purchase this [ __ ] you
needed but all of that changes when he
asks may I see your ID the tone was the
same as it was when he was showing you
the junk you needed friendly-like but
now there's a threat if you don't have
ID who
other than a thieving threat there's a
bright lift to his voice may I see your
ID surely someone change and to say that
just as my mother and father
respectively showed me how important it
was to despise racism and its various
inevitable humiliations and on the other
hand to amplify amplifies with workers
who were quote-unquote oppressed by a
corporate system that puts their head in
a yoke just so they know who's boss who
was the slain who is the victim speak so
wrote Sophocles Antigone and maybe
that's the start of the essay in my head
that I can't write because of the blood
pounding in it as the young man swipes
my card and swipes my reason several
blocks away from my home away from love
the transaction closed the thing I
needed now bagged weighs heavy in my
hand like evil like shame why could my
forego my mother's ethos and me that
young man to filth because why not
looking at me may I have your ID he was
perhaps frightened to discover what he
would find on the other end of his
learned learned question Inquisition at
the beginning or end of his own street
rocky with the stones of compromise
smiling all the while the better to
survive the first time I experienced the
may I see your ID syndrome outside of my
paw and trying to enter his room whose
child are you I was 14 or so or so and
wearing white ballet slippers I was a
student at the School for the Performing
Arts which was then on West 46th Street
in Manhattan there i majored in theatre
to get to the school from my home in
Brooklyn I took the IRT Express the two
or three train and got off at Times
Square I always wore bought white ballet
slippers then and frequently black
tights
sometimes I carried a bag a kind of
pouch my mother made me a queer costume
for her queer child one day as I hurried
through the filthy labyrinth that wasn't
is the IRT subway system at Times Square
a cop stopped me give me your ID
I showed him my train
I didn't have any other idea the black
blood was pounding behind my eyes
something instinct told me to show told
me not to show my real face the face of
my fear and hatred I was no longer
myself I knew what it was like to be
almost annihilated or have some part of
your natural trust annihilated by man
becoming nothing and maybe they won't
kill you when I was a kid my boy cousins
used to try to suffocate me with plastic
bags they wanted this [ __ ] to die
maybe that long ago cop wanted this
traggert to die with no provocation at
all he walked me down some filthy
corridors and we ended up in these
headquarters where I was booked as a
truant I said once that I was not
assured that I was on my way to school
but that wasn't the story you wanted to
hear or his buddy or his buddies wanted
to hear and something in me went silent
how could I contradict the idea of my
body with what my ballet slippers my
mind my love of art and theater and
movie lovers in anguish and let me just
say that when that what I felt then is
not so very different than what I feel
as I walked towards my new home where
Love Waits
I'm adrift in a stop-and-frisk universe
that has always been a stop-and-frisk
universe my silence is a form of
protection do I want them to cut my
tongue out - or an equally effective
private part of my anatomy this feeling
goes back for centuries no doubt and is
in my DNA and I saved my life in the
past all the way back to the ships and
the lash but it has also stomped on my
heart and given love quite a job call it
what you will white backlash Obama era
payback or whatever but I find our
present condition difficult to write
about but we must as writers and
thinkers we must stand in the hard lane
sometimes and he an an even humor and
sometimes beauty and the great keeping
of pain in comprehension - to make sense
of it to be the enemies of what they say
we are but aren't even before I moved
out of my old apartment with all those
body
one can feel the need for blood to be
spilled in the streets an extension of
all the shop bodies in North Carolina or
mow down bodies in Lexington Virginia
not to mention other parts of the world
now and forever somewhere always as I've
said some folks call our present
condition white backlash but I call this
wave of violence the tedium of having to
give a [ __ ] all those years in college
reading beloved all those seminars on
women's bodies including reproductive
rights and dad down at the office having
to deal with having to hear about equal
pay even if you never forked it over all
those years of talk of immigrant clip
care and elder health care and Social
Security this and fare that even
entertainment wasn't safe
tender movie and tender TV [ __ ] about
lesbians and gays and trans people and
will it never end so says the guys
sitting in that classroom or in that
movie theater emboldened by the vile
slimy that comes via the airwaves night
after night so says this guy's he
watches TV reflecting the rich and is
constantly rightly exasperated by all
this different president look love those
immigrants up says this guy
following his commander-in-chief's
example sterilized them separate them
from their children like in the slave
days and let me get mine my stuff once
in my old neighborhood a guy with a BMW
was looking lovingly at the stuff stored
in the hood of his shiny car as his
little son a toddler walked out into the
street and was minding its own and was
minding its own supervise baby business
when the world stopped but really didn't
as the baby toddled taxi a taxi suddenly
rounded the corner near where the baby
was and I screamed the car stopped and
the man stopped looking at his stuff for
a moment to pick up his living stuff
then holding his neglected child this
palo de new home to make sure that i
wasn't going to report him to the police
I should have mom's mask ethos
interfered perhaps the man had learned
something
ma said in my heart while my body said
if I went to the police who would
believe us would I be the dude who
pushed his baby into the road welcome
what caring which fathers looked on
helplessly looking at his BMW stuff that
father a version of my father was
perhaps tired of giving a [ __ ] even when
it came to his own child and its baby
needs maybe he was tired of all those
other baby needs over the past eight
years or so when he had to deal with
imagining how someone else might feel
maybe it was tired of living through
some version of the civil rights era
again all those Obama's it was
exhausting to be made of the world's
concerns all the moral [ __ ] of the
underprivileged and whatnot including
those guys in ballet slippers who scream
when a baby may be harmed who the [ __ ]
wants to deal now it's my turn the same
guy might think my time mine and what I
want to ask is how long what we before
even the most enlightened person starts
calling me the n-word
this guy may say if all those [ __ ]
and [ __ ] out there can't take what
we've had to swallow all these years all
those years of trying to empathize a
crap that has nothing to do with us at
all that has nothing to do with power
surely it's all those [ __ ] and [ __ ]
time to deal with guys we've had to
listen to what what they've had to say
all that whining ignoring the fact that
America was never theirs and always ours
ignoring the fact that America was
always has always heard them first and
because these guys are American they
want me to hear them first here's some
stuff they said they've said that they
that they are surprised you don't want
to listen to as you listen to because of
Maas ethos the body that took it all
because Maul considered her job and a
memorial service where eulogize the
white woman I didn't like but her family
asked me and what can you do one of the
bereaved came up to me and said I've
been reading you for years I didn't know
you were blocked and so big then at a
party out of nowhere I really did like
dear white people as if you're in the
cast at a business meeting with a
potential producer don't you miss that
comedy troupe that used to say I'm black
and I said
at a small theater a small black female
performer in a solo work this show was
over and retired to the men's room for a
moment
a gentleman in the opposite stall you
were so great in the show
then there was a usual mistaking me for
another writer a color of color and when
I said now I'm the other one looking at
me cockeyed was I sure then there's the
guy you go out on a date with before you
find well who tells you that his
relatives owned a plantation and Haiti
years ago and the people who worked it
looked like you sometimes you try to
convince others these guys that you are
yourself where is my idea especially
hideously if they are your friends
remember the moment when the dying woman
you were trying to help said you see
that black guy crossing the street my
grandfather would have called him a Mook
remember the former friend who loved to
tell the story of how when her father
thought someone was unattractive he'd
say they're uglier than a bag of [ __ ]
rectums or the other dying friend who
said while bending over to kiss her whoa
this is just like the Tennessee Williams
story desiring the black masseur this
casual and not so casual hatred and
aggression even in presumed love is as
old as America a country in part defined
by people defining who they are
least not while America is happening to
my body and mind I try to make sense of
it as I walk towards home and love but
my mind can't make writing of it somehow
because how can you tell a story that
all the metaphors in the world can't
enhance or help make into art love wants
so many things once your story without
metaphors if it comes to that love says
tell it baby tell about that walk from
east to west marred and marked by others
that which makes for a different kind of
reflection tell it because love is
and why I write in 1976 talk about her
early years as a writer Joan Didion said
that she borrowed the title of her essay
from another George Orwell's why right
because first off she liked the sound of
the words aye aye aye she writes in many
ways writing his act of saying aye
of imposing oneself upon other people of
saying listen to me see it my way change
your mind it's an aggressive even
hostile act
you can disguise its qualifiers and
tentative subjunctives with ellipses and
evasions but there's no getting around
the fact that sending words on paper is
the tactic of a secret bullying and
invasion and imposition of the writers
sensibility on the readers most private
space rereading Gideon
I wonder if indirectly she's telling us
something about her experience as a
woman and that her and that her
description of aggression was a result
of having been aggressed upon told what
to do claimed putting her aside on more
than one occasion to make a difficult
situation work to pacify a husband to
not be a target just as queer writers of
viewer and writers of color had to smile
and twirl and between bitter
descriptions about life in America in
order to be read at all often the reader
more I'm sorry in order to read at all
often told the reader more about who
they were in between the lines saying I
then not if you're a different person
this can feel like a dangerous
proposition let alone reality being a
target hurts and since writing is the
office deep itself writing about one's
eyes standing up for it can feel like an
aggressive act I suppose giving how us
targets are programmed not to I wonder
how many heteronormative men and some
queer ones worried ones worry when
asking for your ID or saying in so many
words stay out of my room
or where we have aggressive their
language
after they put a plastic bag over your
head trying to smother your [ __ ] voice
and concerns how did we get how do we
get over this that's the subject of life
how do we get here and are we stuck here
as men and women and others living as we
do in a broken world hmm I tend to write
broken fractured things that show power
and power being insistent on showing its
power further by breaking more that's
jailing the innocent cracking love in
the knees the majority of us are not
whole individuals because there's no
such thing as a whole society sometimes
on my walk home in the short space
between the rest of the world in my
front door sometimes I will have a
moment to dream about words and
sometimes these words are images such as
Danny Glover in Danny Glover and this is
America at the end of the piece Glover
black and naked with fear it's chased
down a seemingly endless corridor by
white people the terror and Glover's
eyes and open mouth gasping for breath
it's familiar to me and now to love as
love holds my body not seeing it as the
wrong one but as the one and that's the
thought and feeling that gets me down
the stairs on those days when I leave my
house to walk east to west I have a
little ritual when I close my apartment
door and face my day after checking to
see if I have my ID checking to see if
I'm ready to make the journey once more
I looked across the street at the
colored lobby guys sitting at his
station he's writing unto himself every
day I go out and he's at work in his
glass off world we waved to one another
quietly happy and satisfied to find that
we're still here each in the others
world thank you
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much and I'm happy to
answer any questions or any accusations
[Music]
[Music]
I can tell you who love is that if that
helps get get the ball rolling he's a
nice man and um he comes from a part of
the world where his mother was the
conduit for difference his brother his
older brothers Japanese and then she met
this radical Jewish man in Seattle and
so each of the brothers are
representative of her interest in
difference and for the first time
recently he talked to me about his
brother being stopped on the island
where they grew up because he was
Japanese and it's it's interesting to be
with people or a person who actually can
learn from who you are
and you learned from who they are and so
I wanted to write something where he was
a character but but abstract because
everybody fills in love with the person
that they're close to or the friend or
whatever and I just wanted you to have
your own feeling about what love might
be for you and anyway even though I was
gonna read this tonight but it's okay he
doesn't have to death don't tell and it
was a wonderful way to hear everything
is an education when you get up here I
think the only people who feel
self-confident speaking in public are
usually not very interesting to listen
to and that's because we're all involved
in the act of discovery together and
that's what makes
things like the humanities I think an
important I know that there's a struggle
in certain universities but it'd be
pretty bleak without metaphors and
thinking about metaphors right anyway
it's your idea of love is the whole
point what I was trying to say and
whoever that person is for you just
insert them in those sentences Gary's
gonna give the first okay oh this one
right there this one right there
okay hello hi my question is you said
you wrote this piece once before mm-hmm
and it wasn't received as you wanted it
to be and then you know I said it was I
said it was commodified in a way that I
did not like I do want to know what that
was about
okay so I was asked to maybe I won't
tell you actually because now because
then you can discover it now for
yourself um I think it's online audio
the audio does it become part of the
archive yes and I can tell you
afterwards how's that with that but I
don't want to break the spell now that
you've seen it as it should be it's
organic in your mind yeah you don't need
to know you're too young to know I'm
gonna pull rank age right oh but now
it's organic in your mind and that's
really what I wanted more than anything
I'm so happy that you asked though thank
you it was a young man over there hi
thank you very much that was stunning
oh thank you and thank you for sharing
that because I know it's it's very
intimate and personal
and thank you so much I really um I
don't think there's any point of doing
it unless you're gonna do it you know I
mean that's the Judy Garland in me
probably yeah I I had a sort of question
about and one was is sort of extending
from the revision that you've done women
is sort of different since mm-hmm
there's more of the revision I can talk
about I won't talk about the other
context but it was a lot more about my
father and this man that I love we've
never spoken I've lived there for two
years and every day that I come out and
if he's on duty we just wave to make
sure that we're in the planet and so
there was a lot more about I hadn't
mentioned my father maybe once or twice
in the previous incarnation but it was
important to see him you know and to see
how this idea of having a home was
really from my mother that they were
very separate in that way that her idea
was to be inclusive if you had anything
and his wasn't so I had to draw those
parallels I think right and I think I'm
sort of connected to that I was thinking
through when you were especially
referencing Virginia Woolf because right
now I live in London and the first time
that I went to Richmond which is where
Virginia Woolf was I had this fantastic
realization which is she could have
walked to central London yes you know
when you read her taxes if she's on
another planet yes yes and but it really
is sort of the first time I was saying
in a literary sense about this sense of
like absence absence not only you know
it's not only a spatial consideration
and I was
listening to your talk which was very
beautiful but these sort of plays
between the absence and presence like
that she had the luxury right oh and I
was just wondering if you could if you
could elaborate a bit more on cuz it
seemed like you know we weren't always
in the same temper ality we were always
in the same space but you seem to be
playing back and forth yes been filling
the space of a penis of absence of being
already filled with this interplay and I
was wondering if that was an intention
or if you know for sure
out of it it wasn't it wasn't I can say
it wasn't bad writing it was it was it
was really intentional that I drew a
comparison it's a piece about
comparisons so you have two parents and
one is excessively giving and one
doesn't give and then you're an artist
or a writer in the world and you're not
allowed to be invisible and have your
own thoughts you're watching yourself be
watched by other people so the
experience of of being visible is not a
happy one I think Virginia I went I went
to her house too and it was fascinating
to see how she could go to her sister's
house and come back and there was all
this great freedom in these towns for
her and so I wanted to I think you're
correct in that the space gets filled up
with a lot of my talking but she does it
in a different way she's allowed to
observe
whereas I can't observe without being
caught it or checked so that's what the
envy you know I envy her that that you
can take a long walk in London and write
something beautiful about it unharmed
really that's what it comes down to and
so I would like to know what that feels
like one day I felt it once in my life
and that was in Stockholm weirdly and my
partner said he had never seen me look
relieved that we went to a museum the
hotel was right near the modern museum
so we could walk up the hill and we went
into this I went into the shop and the
woman said is Marta here Marta hi Oh
March is the person who sent us to this
great hotel and dong and the woman at
the desk
I was ready right I was ready like and
like I'm buying I'm looking at cards and
she says very gently may I help you
would you prefer English or Swedish when
she mentioned one other language and I
was like what like I said it didn't know
so then we my partner met when we walked
to the town down to I guess the downtown
area and we were waiting on line to go
to this place that Martin had
recommended and the waiter said oh and
there was there were other people and
he's and I just expected you know
they're gonna serve these other people
and and he said oh you've been waiting
so long dude would you like a drink and
ice truly had never been in the world
like this in my life and there are
pictures of me like it's sort of your
reborn when people treat you like
another person they're looking at you
and saying what language can I
communicate with you in or you even
waiting here would you like a cocktail
while you're waiting I had never been in
such a civilized environment in my
European environment in my life and so
that was the one occasion where I didn't
feel that people talked to me about the
experience of being in Stockholm they
didn't talk to me about being an
American and Stockholm and in touch with
me about
[Music]
there was there was no category so just
to test it just because it's it's fun to
I took a taxi to go see Greta Garbo's
grave because you you're in Stockholm
and the driver said oh would you like me
to wait a taxi driver and I said okay
and he said I think you can get
information about where she is in that
there was like a little cafe a little
Hut and I went in and and the waitress
was just cranky because she was a
waitress and she was tired and I said
can you tell me what Garbo's gravis
please and she said oh everybody wants
to see that everybody it wasn't what you
brought dude doing in Stockholm in this
graveyard with a taxi driver waiting but
it was an extraordinary feeling some
more - thank you for that it's great
people and it was it was something that
I will write about as the first
experience of freedom in a place that I
had never in my life experience
I don't know other people who have
perhaps been there but it was just a
very different scene the last bit about
Sweden that Stockholm that was really
great was we were walking we were
sitting on a bench and I sneezed and the
cutest gate wing said oh consumers you
know how are you gesundheit
am i my partner like what is this place
and so to fill it up with I think that
the absence for me in the piece is the
experience I don't have a freedom that
Virginia has and that you know the cops
have or whatever but we're all locked in
a system the thing that makes us free or
is our mind and she was able to explore
her mind and
I'm envious of that yeah also Chrissy
Jones has like eight kids in Stockholm I
was watching that documentary and I was
like I get it but they're all like
Popeye it was great it was the greatest
how they have ever have well I think I
will then take do my due diligence this
is the director of the center and ask
you a question
and and first of all I want to say
Quincy Jones my goodness one of the
strangest things that one doesn't know
about Quincy Jones so many people don't
is that he was the producer of all of
Leslie Gore's hits yes that's right it's
my party and I'll cry if I want to
reduce my Quincy Jones yeah in any case
I'm a terrible terrible husband with a
great father
all those kids adore interesting yeah so
fun fair so Hilton that this was you
know I've I've watched a lot of talks by
visiting Frankie fellows over the last
years and some of them have been
marvelous talks
none of them have been as moving or as
important I would say as this one by a
longshot and and it reminds me of
something that I've been wondering and
I've been wanting to talk to you about
since the early weeks of the semester
you've been coming to Wednesday lunches
where there are fellows faculty fellows
and each each week a faculty fellow
gives a short talk and then there is
conversation about the talk afterwards
and it's fun too it's fun too because
the such different feels it's fun to
email them when I suggest a book or that
is related it's great that people are
open and and you have been tremendously
generous and open to this experience and
and at the same time you've asked a
couple of questions that had just a
little bit of a point to them I thought
which which were signaling something
that is lacking in what you're seeing in
the approach to of humanists in the
university that is so abundantly clear
in what you do in your own
writing and it's not just of course I'm
not suggesting that you're saying what
one is creative the others not creative
um but there's a different kind of
creativity involved and yet many of us
humanists aspire to kind of get just a
little bit closer to inch a little bit
closer to the kind of creativity that
was so much on on display here and the
moving and personal investment and stake
and so on and so forth that comes across
very very directly in in in what you
what you have given to us today thank
you so can you tell us a little bit more
about this oh I just think I think it's
I don't think it's such a big mystery I
think that academic life can be very
cordoned off and people are often afraid
to talk to each other for fear of being
ignorant of their field or you know not
having much experience with science or
law or whatever has been discussed but
the thing that unites us is language
we've all had to stand up and give a
presentation or or talk about ideas and
the only way that we can really do that
is with words so after I was frightened
for the first two I think you know there
was a law talk and then I can't remember
the second person's evil music was it
can he leave on music and then there was
a Russian lady and so the thing that was
so moving to me was that they were
frightened to to be in a kind of mixed
group of people and the thing that you
can approach people always with scholars
academics artists is a thought or
language and that's when I started to
feel that we were all connected we were
just frightened by what the Academy had
taught certain people or you know it's
intimidating for other folks but we
share that so if you can just say I
really love what you said I didn't
understand this part or have you ever
read people are so hungry to have those
it was touching it's almost as if we
were all 12 years old again a nerds and
reading you know it's great
there's a wonderful characterization
thank you very much for exactly what is
so valuable about a Humanities Center
yes as opposed to the departments that
we all live in and spend most of our
yeah yeah and that's also you you know
if you're in a particular department
you're preoccupied with those that
depart with concerns and you know you
don't get you don't get out much hint
that much anymore and so I think that
it's in who says my mother would say to
you know build that bridge and say I
really liked
for instance that young Indian scholar
working on law in South Africa and India
and he had never read my Paul and so he
emailed me and because I said oh I'll
just send you a list of things and I
sent him a list of things and he was
thrilled and so we chatted more about
things so it's it's um I just think it's
it takes five minutes to be kind
basically and it kind of dispels dispels
fear kindness last chance
hi so this is sort of a I guess a
follow-up of that you cited and sort of
frame Didion oh and I guess this would
be the point where I wanted to hear you
sort of elaborate on well do you do you
buy her position it certainly doesn't
sound like it but it'd be interesting to
have you sort of more directly counter
or expand with her yeah yeah well it's
so funny because I just finished writing
a long thing about a novel of hers that
I love called The Book of Common Prayer
and it's her most inhabited but because
it's about two women trying to connect
it's a romance between two women and
there's a fascinating quote in her and
piece about Ernest Hemingway where she
says that part of his strength was not
attaching that you're distant and that
you're not attaching and the tragic
characters in her novels are always
women who want to attach and so when I
read this talk why I write it's really
beautiful because it's about failure and
she talks about how she cause she's not
a thinker that because she has a
novelist mind that she did dwells in the
concrete and that was not pertinent to
what I wanted to say to my what I wanted
to say was you know this act of being a
secret bully that you're internally you
want to convince people of what you're
saying you know it's it's rhetoric but
it's also real you know you want people
to hear you and listen to you so I think
I believe her in this and I believe her
and actually more into her fiction I
love her writing but I her fiction is
much more hidden and you have to kind of
go in there and and see how she split
offs between she splits off between the
rational person that you know in the
essays and this romantic woman who's
adrift
there are a couple of moments in this
essay which is very deeply moving
just a couple No there are a couple of
moments yeah of comedy in it
yes um and I would just love to hear you
talk about those moments and
specifically how they're framed around
language like you're giving certain
characters language where they're asking
you questions that are somewhat
ridiculous
and then another moment that I found
comedic was when you said oh and now I'm
speaking at this funeral for this white
woman that I didn't know is true so how
it's sort of I mean it's a comedy of
it's truly a comedy of manners right
like you're a well-brought-up
person which means generally that you've
had a good mother who says you know you
stand up you open the door for the lady
you walk on the outside of the you know
towards the curb all the things that a
mother teaches you because a boy because
maybe somebody didn't do it for her or
you're her ideal husband this person
that she's made basically and I mean
what could be more perfect
like you make your husband and and you
guys know what I'm talking about yes yes
yes so the comedy is goes back to the
split between the parents and so you
have a father who's very shut off but
you have this mother who's excessively
accommodating or kitten up I would say
careful and caring about other people so
the comedy is you have all these lessons
and you in a world where people are
mannerless like they do have to they do
not have your quality of manners or your
spirit or whatever but you still have
this machinery and I think you've picked
up on something that I'm trying now to
explain
or right about is what do you do when
you have that machinery that's actually
sort of antiquated in today's world that
people don't see or listening to I
wanted to write that section to say that
actually people don't they're not
talking to you they're talking to some
idea about you but that's right it's
still painful they're still words but
it's not you that's what I wanted to say
hi mr. Allison thank you very much thank
you um I'm not gonna pretend to have
read Ralph Ellison's the invisible man
recently but for whatever reason this
this piece reminded me a lot of that
thank you
and I was you know you talked about
walking east and west and I know the
character and in the book in Allison's
book is talking about being invisible
because people refuse to see them and
you're talking about not necessarily
being invisible but falling silent
because people are seeing you they're
not seeing the real you but they're
seeing you but also I think in Ellison's
book the character is taking a bite out
of a yam and taking a bite out of a yam
I think and a yam oh yeah oh yeah okay
yes okay okay yeah um but the character
talks about taking a bite and how or
passing them I'm not even sure if they
took a passing the M and there was a
smell that hit them and and there being
light and vibrancy that hadn't
previously been within the pages okay
but we also know that these characters
is seeking a lot of light and I'm just
wondering if you could talk about or
elaborate on a feeling of light you
talked about Sweden my own apartment and
that there's a lot of light in it I
think that's a that's a pertinent
question
I think white as affects you differently
so for instance if I'm in London and I
see a show of paintings there's there's
a layer of gray over the paintings
because it's a grey City and the light
that's coming through is gray but when I
am in New York the thing that I love or
San Francisco in particular are
gradations of light that happen all the
time so I don't think I'm going to
expand on the light in the apartment I'm
flattered to be you know anywhere near
what he's written I wish I remembered
the am but home but I do appreciate his
because light is energy and it's also so
energy of sustenance and I think it's
kind of a metaphor about feeding about
not only visibility but feeding and
being warned and possessed in some way
other than is being seen I don't think
that's my concern here so much but maybe
it'll turn out now I'll go read the book
again and put something in just because
you were clever enough to see that thank
you
I called you hi it's such an honor to
see you thank you and thank you for that
incredible talk thank you
I I have this question that is not fully
formed but I'm gonna start and hope okay
we'll get to the question mark I was
thinking about what you said about
Virginia Woolf being able to be in the
environment and how the text allows
description of the environment to become
a kind of metaphor of the interior space
and how for you
the intrusion of racism and the
monitoring and the policing of the black
body a disallows a kind of ability to I
mean one sees the environment but to use
the environment in the way that wolf use
is it in the tag you know I'm thinking
about even a section like time passes to
the White House and so I so I was
thinking like what relationship has
white projections and racism created
between metaphor interior tea and right
you know it in the act of writing I mean
one of the things that I resent and I
think I said it in this is that it it
jumbles those feelings so that your the
clarity of that those three points of
rhetoric becomes a mess but here's
something about Virginia that will be
very helpful to me that I really want to
go back and talk about is I've read I
know that I'm one of three people have
read all of Leonard Wolf's autobiography
in there five I told Amy to read them
too and I tortured her and um and he
talks about how women would make fun of
her on the streets because of her
clothing which was very important to her
and it was always about style in that
fashion and girls would start to laugh
and women her peers would laugh at her
and there's a line I think in MI snob
where she goes had to try and lingerie
and she's very uncomfortable it involves
she said I'm no nice with suspenders me
orders and things and I mean to go back
and say that she has those moments for
sure but she also has a home she has a
protector she has other people who look
like her so she's able to not even sort
of skirt on the margins and feel wrong
she feels wrong internally and I feel
wronged externally which affects the
internal of course so if anything that
affects the internal affects your
rhetoric because that's you that
metaphor is you the ideas you the
speaking is you so that's what I resent
is that it gets disrupted by the sound
of someone else's voice or behavior so
if this guy at the store for instance
never asked me that question there would
be no memory of being asked that
question in that context so it's a kind
of 50/50 right you get the gift of the
story but then what gets taken away as
the rhetoric and the metaphor as a clear
point of entry that is that helpful
yeah exactly when I think about the fact
that wolf killing herself and drowning
means that she has been absorbed by the
very landscape that she is hidden yes
throughout that and it was fascinating
to go to where she lived with Leonard in
the country because it was that she has
a separate house like she had a separate
place and to see how she could walk to
her sisters and walk back she couldn't
she could do it being unseen like he
would you know be in the other house so
there was the freedom of being
unremarked upon and she has that great
thing when she was very jealous of
Katherine Mansfield and she said I
walked out and and I was stomping on the
ground saying I exist I
if I exist and so it's almost like do I
dare exists it's from that's me do I
dare and she says I can't I do and I say
do idea yeah thank you
hmm I think people the sort of parts for
wine please join us please join me in
thanking help Naz once more
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]